he was one of the cold war's most
infamous double agents
a former mi6 officer who betrayed his
country
to spy for the soviet union
in russia george blake is seen as a hero
after passing information that unmasked
hundreds of covert british agents
in eastern europe but here he's seen as
the ultimate traitor
after some of the agents he exposed were
executed
it's rather like if you imagine you're
in a football team
and you're in the cup final and a member
of your own team
at the crucial moment turns around and
kicks the ball into your own net
deliberately
that's the kind of sickening feeling you
have about a traitor blake's own cover
was blown in 1961.
he was sentenced to 42 years in london's
wormwood scrubs prison but he didn't
stay very long
escaping after five years in a plot
straight from the pages of a spy
thriller
blake managed to scale these walls with
the help of three former inmates who
threw him a rope from out here
after making his getaway he spent two
months in hiding before being smuggled
across the channel in a camper van
and driven to east germany blake was
hidden in a wooden box
attached underneath blake never regarded
himself as a traitor
claiming he never felt british he was
born in holland and acquired citizenship
through his father
he defected after being captured during
the korean war
and remained an ardent supporter of
communism even after
the soviet union fell if we had it had
been able to
build a society which was both just
where there was equality and where there
was an
abundance of goods as was the intention
and abundance of goods then uh
of course the so the soviet empire
wouldn't have
disintegrated are you a friend of his
yes i am his friend the war reporter
philip dean was held captive in career
alongside blake
and became one of his defenders i think
he accepted
to be a patty in a double agent game so
that
his conviction would prove to the
russians that the false information he
fed them was true
blake lived out his years in moscow
where he remained one of the uk's most
wanted criminals
a spy who'll never be forgiven for
spying on his own
iva bennett sky news